all right so this guy made a video
called the epidemic of Andrew Tate
clones with Andy King and um I'm in the
thumbnail and you see that kid oh you're
in the thumbnail yeah look at that yeah
look at you and this kid in the middle
his name's um Riley he's just this um
this other this other marketer that I
know pretty funny so that they're that
they're coming up I love these videos
Man free publicity that's 122 000 views
on my personal brand that's awesome
we're looking at Andrew take copycats
now Andrew Tate of course renowned for
being Andrew Tate but we're not talking
about Andrew Tate today we're going to
be looking at the copycats that have
emerged following copycats I'm excited
the main premises they all claim to be
kind of alpha successful guys most of
them are already five million dollars
okay successful we'll see as we get into
it okay let's see let's see if you were
over the age of 13 and you still use
Snapchat I just want you to know that
you're a little [__] especially if
you're still keeping snap streaks if you
make it a point of your day to keep this
minuscule number we're going you have
nothing better to do in your life look
at that as a sign that you need to wake
the [__] up and escape this [__] trap
this is hard right because you don't get
mad but I agree with that oh I agree
with him too I agree 100 I agree with
them for a fact that he had just deleted
Snapchat I feel like a week before 100
or he actively has streaks and the way
that he first comes
I do have Snapchat on my phone right now
but I do not Snapchat anybody I Snapchat
two girls because I'm a man and I have
to Snapchat some girls like and you if
they don't want to text you got to snap
them I'm in group chats and I have
friends where I only talk to them but I
do not keep snap streaks that's Haram
and Snapchat is indeed a waste of time
so don't keep streaks I'm going to stand
by this but like you know a lot of us do
have contacts on specific apps so like
I'll literally delete Snapchat and then
re-download it to check in on it so like
I'll re-download it a couple times a day
to snap the girls back and stuff and
then I'll delete it so I don't check it
throughout the day and I know that's
really stupid but I know that if I keep
Snapchat on my phone then I'm gonna
check it throughout the day so I just
delete it and then re-download it I know
that's really dumb Snapchat runs your
life huh well no I I kind of have
Snapchat by the by the balls right now
because I'm deleting it I'm like it's
like that girl where it's like you're in
you're out you're in so stay away you
know what I'm saying Zane was like if
you still have Snapchat you're a little
[__] you're a [__] you're a [__]
loser he's definitely one of those kids
that would like be like these are the
tips that you need to survive high
school and they're all wrong yeah he
doesn't know [__] there's no [__] about
it also [__] that's what I'm addressing
oh [__] yeah you know the clips
underneath like oh yeah yeah I mean
that's how he's gonna get the attention
yeah I have always known that I'm gonna
become rich and successful since before
I was making any [__] money
he definitely just learned how to curse
too he's one yeah I you know I agree
with you yeah we need to not Carlos
that's what I'm saying
he's like maybe he has made a little
money but like now he's like oh I got
the right of passage like [__] everyone
[__] you brookies 100 bill in his hand
for the first time and he was like
even back in my broken days when I was
still working at a bar the bartenders
did he actually say broke yes that
sounds derogative
that sounds really derogatory doesn't it
dude self-deprecating so yeah I was
saying it about myself I was a Brokey I
was working at a bar that's broke it was
the Brokey day it's working for like 20
bucks an hour I don't know about it if
it was broken you broke he has a lot to
do with mentality wouldn't that make you
more of a wagy than a Brokey yeah but
you know it's tick tock come on I'm
trying to understand you know I'm just
I'm sorry I was a broken I had like
maybe a few thousand dollars or whatever
I was making pretty good money on Tick
Tock back then actually but I I was in
like the the money Matrix I was like I
gotta get my taxable income up so that's
why I was working there yeah let's keep
going that's a little [__] up it's
directly taken from Andrew Tate Andrew
Tate says broke that's a big thing
I didn't even know that answers I have
no idea he says wages too they're
probably derogatory even in my group I
was making any [__] money
back in your broken days like five
months ago yeah dude like how much money
are you even making from this back when
I was 17 years old
talking to me and making plans I see a
lot of the red pill guys like they get
mad but like I think this is funny like
I laugh at this yeah so far and it's
like good humor like they're just like
you know they're joking around yeah
they're they're like nice people when
I'm older and Rich if you don't even
display that confidence and believe in
yourself that you're gonna make it one
day how do you ever expect to achieve
your goals yes you need to take all the
proper steps to Achieve Financial
Freedom and whatnot but you also need to
truly believe it in yourself and know
that you're going to make it there one
day most absurd thing about this to me
is that everything that he's saying is
completely valid yeah he is not the one
that should be telling you yeah any of
this also why were the bartenders
talking about his his yacht you always
got to believe in yourself get other
people to talk about your yacht and then
well it's because when you believe in
yourself that much that energy literally
radiates to other people like I'm not I
didn't make that up at all like I
remember working at the bar and like my
wife anina he was saying like I'm gonna
bartend on your yacht one day because I
was talking about money and I was
posting money tick tocks right so that's
because they knew who you are and who
you were in that moment and they were
yeah talking about your future and then
I remember one of the regulars it's
conversation and then I remember one of
the regulars there I told them that I'm
gonna buy a house within like two years
of working here and like the reason I'm
here is for taxable income for like you
know to be able to pay for the house and
they were like that's crazy like I talk
about that in this so yeah come on that
[__] later in life and you got to
believe in yourself it's like it's got
like a little bit of Truth there it's
all right like yeah believe in yourself
get that [__] done but like what was
that story the bartenders are coming
into work every day like yeah man my
girlfriend just dumped me I'm I've been
having a really rough
like nah hey guys hold on can I can I
speak over you for a second yeah when do
you guys think I'm gonna get a yacht and
then I won't invite you because
um
my boy's not like that oh that's cute
though oh what is this that was funny
these guys are funny I like them one of
the things that I've learned a lot about
in the past couple years is discipline
get control of your head control your
mind and learn discipline and so you
stop talking yourself out of things and
so you know Tom Shea the Navy SEAL who
we work with I went through his 21 day
challenge where he gave me some tasks to
do every day and part of the challenge
was to wake up every day commit to doing
it and every time I started to talk
myself out of it I would have an excuse
run through my head some lame ass excuse
and there are four main excuses that he
teaches people that are that ruin lives
that's why we're doing the 21 Day
Challenge again together which Sunny is
not excited about because he's gonna
have Tom on his ass if you guys actually
would like to do that with us go to the
link in the description because there's
a discount code come and do it because
guaranteed in one area of your life
there's something you're not doing
because you talk yourself out of it
every day you can go to the top of the
description click the link and and buy
it with code Sunny fast50 for a nice
discount and we'll be doing it with you
guys we'll be in the zoom calls and
everything it'll be cool takes two to
cure depression I wonder if any [__]
wild clay wait that's wild wild right
two weeks depression can be cured it's
done you don't need pills you don't need
therapy I've never been to the doctor in
my life yeah [__] that doctors I don't
want to hear any of this [__] that
it takes years and thousands of dollars
in therapy and dozens of pills to cure
depression no right now stop hanging out
with your loser Friends start eating
healthier go to the gym and write your
[__] goals down you need some
direction in your life what does he
think like a cartoonish like shoving a
ton of pills down your throat what do
you think therapy pills
my point was that people typically
revert to pills when they're depressed
rather than you know make making better
life habits which is the real reason why
they're depressed
and I think I've said this before you
really depends on the depression if it's
circumstantial if it's deeper if there's
like heavy duty PTSD trauma sometimes
you need pills to get you to where you
can start making those changes that you
suggested which are all really good
ideas and then you can you know get
yourself off the pills when the time is
right but I could see why a 19 year old
young man giving giving tremendous life
advice is if he knows everything about
everything would be uh you know fodder
for these people like you kind of got to
give them give them you know
yeah that's funny all right is that
isn't that an Andrew Tate thing like he
thinks that pills are like if you if you
take pills to like cure depression like
you can't speak on
like the quality yeah I'm gonna try to
speak directly to that I'm not sure I
can speak directly on um on the words of
Andrew Tate yeah I mean basically
basically basically why would I listen
to someone someone's advice on
depression that takes pills to be able
to function that's like so valid in my
opinion it's like listen to someone that
doesn't need pills and knows better
that's just fine that that leaves out
real trauma PTSD um where there's where
the brain is so screwed up that it you
need to you need a boost yeah but that's
like that's a that's a total like I know
that's kind of his point yeah
but you have a purpose and know what
you're actively working towards any of
this oh I have chemical depression stuff
it's all complete get rid of that from
your head well it's saying that
depression is is chemically
in your brain okay sure so he's saying
that you can cure it because it's not
actually chemically in your brain it's
just a mindset that you can fix yeah see
I don't think that's what he's saying at
all I think he meant to say clinical
no I think you're wrong with that one go
to the gym and write your [__] goals
down you need some direction in your
life this is a joke and know what you're
actively working towards any of this oh
I have chemical depression stuff is all
complete [__] I changed my mind
you did say chemical but clinical
depression uh my understanding is that
it's like they are they say it's a
chemical imbalance so the term could be
probably lightly interchanged I know you
know yeah I don't really care yeah my
point stands point stands irregardless
they're just picking depression dude I
was wrong I'm sorry dude I'm sorry about
that one [__] I was so wrong I feel like
a really dainty handshake [__] idiot
but like cool sound effects
you're depressed because of your
circumstances not because of this mental
disease start improving yourself and
putting yourself in a better situation
and you'll feel better there is such
thing as situational depression yeah but
you the put yourself in a situation that
doesn't make you actually if we're gonna
nitpick that's circumstantial depression
not situational
yeah you have clinical depression just
like cut off your parents yeah your
parents don't love you your parents want
you to run away dude I feel like we're
saying some awful [__] right now we it's
just me you know what I gotta I gotta
defend you on this one Sonny because
there there's so much in what you're
saying that change yourself change your
circumstances and your mind will change
and for people you know people with
victim mentality just want to be like
but everything sucks around me so I'm
just gonna sit in this dark room and be
sad and that sucks and when you can
finally come out of that and realize
that you have some control over your
mindset and your emotional state of mind
it's so freeing it's so freeing yeah 100
yeah you know there's just I don't even
know if I told this in a video but I had
a trip to Tulum Mexico two weeks ago and
my dumbass thought Tulum was where
Tijuana is so on the west coast oh so I
thought that I was going three hours
back so when I saw my flight was only
two hours I was like okay I'm actually
having a five hour flight and the thing
is I had a 9 A.M flight and since my
sleep schedule is so bad I just stayed
up through the night until this 9 A.M
flight so I get there I'm like literally
ready to pass out I I get on the plane
and I fall asleep and I wake up I I
wasn't awake once while the plane was in
the air I fell asleep when I was on the
plane and woke up when I was supposed to
leave and I was like wow that was five
hours of sleep that was great and so for
like almost the rest of the full day I
thought I was on the West Coast time and
I thought that I had five hours of sleep
but I had two hours I was literally
running on two hours of sleep and then I
realized that I only had two hours and I
was like wow like this whole day I've
been like fully awake and felt fine
because I believed that I had five hours
but realistically I only had two and if
I knew I had two I would have been like
I need caffeine I need a nap a needle
you know what I'm saying and I was like
wow that's green wow yeah that's good we
talk about that a lot the power of the
mind to push through just wanted to talk
about that real quick let's keep going I
don't even know what else they're
reacting right before we did this video
you lost a game of chess online with
some guy and you were like
and I was like snap out of it and you
did yeah yeah yeah [__] one of the
most important lessons my mom taught me
is that there's always something you can
be doing she taught me this when I was
still working at a restaurant in my
broken days there's always water to be
poured dishes to be ran food ran to the
cooks there's always something you can
be doing now that I'm an entrepreneur
having generated over five million
dollars I recognize there's always
something that I can be doing whether
it's automating a business filming
content doing some type of work there's
always something that you should be
doing no time now what I hate about
these guys is that they brag about how
much money they make but it's all from
paid discords that's all it is yeah
right so that's his exact business model
actually wasn't but yeah and it's called
get [__] done Academy
yes thank you where he just puts in
other YouTube videos and stuff makes a
course out of it but he's not my course
is [__] fire bro like I don't even
want to hear any banter about the get
[__] done Academy because that course is
changing lives it literally is I teach
people how the exact organic marketing
strategies that I use to generate all
this money I have a whole e-commerce
course I do multiple live calls a week I
have assignments to test these skills I
give away money to the community for
people who apply and level up I have a
Navy SEAL who made a mindset section I
have other people that are making
business organization sections like
there's so much stuff to learn from from
my Academy yeah I am not even gonna
listen to this banter and what's
hilarious about it is that that is a
relatively new Venture that's only a few
months old I've barely even made money
off of it I've literally reinvested
everything you've been pouring money
pouring time and money into building it
and that has nothing to do with the five
million dollars but but from uh you know
his lips to God's ears I don't blame you
for thinking another five million yeah
let's go yeah but he didn't do any
homework but that's okay he's 19. also
with this one specifically no advice no
no a little bit of advice in that my mom
told me that while I was working my
restaurant job that there is still stuff
you can be doing like doing your job
yeah he's like watching no oh bro let me
I'll answer life is like chess as Tate
would say so if life is like chess
there's always a best move that you
could be making so if right now rather
than filming this video I could be
playing chess I could be doing some
other [__] I could be watching TV
what's the better chess move probably
filming this video that's gonna get me
thousands of views and more publicity
and then people will clip it up and get
me millions of more views there's a move
that I can make even I could make
another good move you know there's the
best move that I can make and there's a
good move I could have read a good book
I would teach me something that's still
a good move but there's always something
that you can be doing and I don't think
people realize that you know people will
just be like I have nothing to do right
now so I'm just gonna watch TV and [__]
off but there is something you can be
doing there's a new video on on
understanding money that you could watch
there's a new program you could join
there's no way you could try making
money and people just don't think like
that what's your point
I am just so pleased that something I
said you're welcome I know I'm the best
but stuck with stuck with you really as
your mother I'm really happy and that is
exactly right
um I I knew somebody once that used to
just [__] and moan and [__] and moan
that he that he didn't have time to go
to the gym and he would be like just do
some push-ups in the living room just do
push-ups do sit-ups you don't have to
you know you don't have time but you
have time to watch TV and to complain do
something about what you want and you
know that's exactly what you just said
there's always something that you can be
doing to get towards your goal and the
fact that these two guys who I who I am
very much enjoying watching them no
offense fellas the fact that you're
you're just rejecting that knowledge
because it came from a 19 year old
entrepreneur it's just kind of a mistake
it's just a mistake but that's okay
let's go I can do other things in that
job I can do other other things at that
I could bring food to the people paying
me to bring food yeah I can actually be
doing my job that's crazy that's [__]
insane dude the first thing that I think
of whenever I start a new business is
how can I Market it on Tick Tock because
it's free right if you're looking to
test what was that crazy video angle
here can we refresh that did I steal
that room
oh wait did I accidentally steal the
second angle from him again I think of
whenever I start a new business is how
can I move yo this guy sucks yo this
guy's a [__] idiot this why is he
doing multiple cameras Oh my god dude
what a [__] broke he only has what
two [__] cameras
that's derogatory Brokey God this guy's
so poor oh my God he's oozing with
poorness yeah
[__] [__] [__]
here I enjoyed this video you know what
are your thoughts I really enjoyed it I
don't know what are these guys names
I don't know Gunner and Andy I guess
Connor or Nancy okay good job guys
roasting my son good job roasting my son
thank you guys for reacting to me thank
you guys for watching this video of me
reacting to them reacting to me follow
me on Instagram at Sonny fast join the
get [__] done Academy it's fire it's
actually really useful information it's
actually getting about to get really
robust too we're working on a lot of new
stuff but a lot of new content that's
coming in my mom's making a section on
how to be a gentleman like bro this like
it's just actually dope as [__] but all
right thank you guys so much for
watching and I'll see you later
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings